are you excited to go to your first UFC
this week I've been training at the
house dude doing tiger rolls in the yard
that stranded up when you go I would
shave your head I was I meant to tell
you that I think they're gonna pick on
you
uh-oh you think I would shave your head
just so you fit in because you're gonna
stick out I don't want you get bullied
while we're I had or something good idea
yeah we're I had like a scarf he ruined
hard for your boy doesn't worry
Woori a do the diamond diamond cutter
hollow is about to get [ __ ] cut son
yeah Holloway's that fools go baby you
don't [ __ ] with the diamond though for
sure you want to bet on it you got that
Holloway's that cow because you're
calling him boy you guys about to get
[ __ ] sold at the mall for a couple
ji-sun all the way so straight up he is
man I was ocean killer dude is just so
like every it's just yeah you fight yeah
you want to bet on it
huh you're poor Hayes boy you guys from
the same hometown yeah same home school
what uh I'll bet we want bad bro
Olay know I love Dustin Poirier this is
just a simple yes black and white does
you know I love you and your wife both
of them are white I think Holloway could
be Latino these definitely Hawaiian by
here is he really
he's flying yeah from why bro yeah but
Hawaii Hawaii what does it do that's
basically Western Latinos the Mexicans
of the island yeah yes they call it some
people call them water Mexicans so
apologize for my racist friend and I'm
sorry and I I also you might be right I
like Hawaii mhm
a lot of good people over there okay so
what are you talk - a vice does we call
oh yeah well there's a lot more to them
than just some product they make you
know they're an indigenous people they
come from long histories of Native
American culture Kuna Matata yeah that's
what I'm saying yeah bro so what you
want to bet I don't know what are you
doing I think you already have an idea
no I don't money's not that fun is it if
you make it I can't afford a bet it yet
you're out your goddamn mind you could
bet dude you have money dude give me
money tattoo on your arm you have money
you have money so like 19 shows in San
Jose yeah but not at that good of deals
Emanuel you've been making the money man
come on what do you want to bet uh I'm
gonna bet a grand a grand grant that's
crazy man is it but it's at least we
have cheddar in the game and you're
gonna 40 I'll do 40 $40 yeah I'd really
just kicked me in the nightclub and
that's not fun what do you mean it's not
fun every dogs got fun put your money
where your mouth is dude yeah okay let's
do a grand oh I'll do I'll do how about
this how about if because he hmm come on
man I'm gonna kick to the nuts yeah you
already said that
no I'm saying whoever loses gets kicked
on the not our man yeah that's not fun
yeah then what if something happens to
one of us when we get hurt and I know
then you can't have kids anymore
yeah which I I don't think I can have
you don't think you can have them I
don't think so I think I mean I haven't
seen you look like a stay-at-home dad
really yeah you dress like one well
thanks dude just without the kids yeah I
got this new shirt actually well I
little g-star wrong it's nice dude I dig
it man you're making Bank now what could
we bet if you don't want a better grant
fund oh five hundo no guy what are you
talking about I'll bet you $50 I went up
to 50 so either accept it or don't let's
start the freaking show you're doing huh
hundred dollars no you look like a guy
that plays [ __ ] sixta bass right now
well [ __ ] New Jersey is that your
where she's staying babe it is yeah you
see the back of that hit oh so low
you're going to jail bro I like that
first team off first league softball
baby Wow really look I straight flex
acun right now bro you're Fergus way
like [ __ ] Manny Ramirez oh yeah Manny
Ramirez put yours on so you look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Ryan Sandberg
you look like rhinestones Sandberg
sexiest guy that comes to fix kill
cranes row that are broken at restaurant
oh you look like the backup quarterback
of a ball blind team
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]